thank you brother and one last thing
before he dives in we want to do a
little askgaryvee with him Gary these
we're gonna have to look at this screen
here
really our own little gary vee thing and
unfortunately we moved these screens was
gonna be a little hard to see but if you
guys can put up the askgaryvee card
collector edition this would be great
card collector challenge gary talks a
lot about how he's a baseball card guy
he was in the past and so when i
interviewed him in his office in the
fishbowl there when i was talking it was
cool there was things going around he
was looking around like it was okay okay
Keith Shawn here this is great and then
I said let's talk about baseball cards
his aunt Anna's went way up he got super
excited and dialed in so let's just go
into this challenge shall we Gary the
very first challenge
let's turn Gary's mic on check check
cuz areas hey Greg shuts hat I'm pumped
here we go very first question is this
what box does this maker belong to
- ah darkness don't sleep on my skills
question number two [ __ ] I'm so pumped I
got that right
what is the name can you see this one
over there go ahead okay oh I have no
idea whom the guide Nolan Ryan shared
his rookie card with a Koosman Koosman
isn't happy alright question number
three I hate this [ __ ] guy what year
and make is this basketball card ninety
flavor yes yes guys guys you all know me
this is the only thing I gave a [ __ ]
about for eight years of my life think
about that much intensity to point
against one little narrow thing next
question we only have a couple more next
question
whose rookie card is this Ernie Banks
yes sir he banks next question this is a
Don Russ blank rookie card rated rookie
rated rookie is correct and we have one
more what year and make is this card
eighty tops 81
I got a wrong eighty oh so it's that I
got it wrong because I thought it was 80
is it eighty oh this is 83 83 top one
last question and I'm super impressed
because I was in color collector who is
this player Roberto Clemente and the
winner is Roberto Clemente Gary the
stage is here is my man
I'm gonna be so upset about that Ozzie
Smith [ __ ] up for the rest of the night
thanks for having me
um so mainly to be very honest with you
I'd really prefer to do Q&A once I saw
the two mics up there I thought wow this
is great so feel free I'd like to spend
most of the 45 minutes to an hour to do
Q&A feel free to like start lining up
now I'm gonna pontificating about a
couple things number one as I caught the
end of Shawn's talk I think it's really
interesting to talk about hustle and
magic as you sit here in the audience I
asked myself what what's practical
what's practical can you go home and
create more magic can you go home and
create more magic I'm not sure right I
think we could talk about that a little
bit I think it has a lot to do with
self-awareness I think a lot of you in
this room want to be something instead
of reverse-engineer what you actually
are but can you really go home and
become Shawn and and have that level of
charisma and and have that I don't know
I've always felt that talent could be
honed you could maximize by the way your
kicks are phenomenal um I think you can
maximize your talent like I feel like I
have a certain amount of you know
basketball talent in my body sure I can
play every day but can i really get to
that extreme level where i could be on a
basketball card just punchline the
answer's no I do not believe that you
sit here you fly into Vegas you sit up
here and listen to all these great
speakers a lot of my homies have spoke
earlier and I don't think you go home
and scale magic and so I love Shawn with
all my heart but here's one thing I can
promise you you can all go home and
hustle more and the reason I push hustle
so much is because it feels like the
most [ __ ] controllable thing to
change the outcome of what disappoints
you
it's just the most controllable thing I
don't know how you know there's gonna be
a lot of stuff that people are gonna
talk about during this weekend I don't
know you know yes yes I think you should
all go home and become dramatically more
charismatic I think he should do that
how and so I think the answer to how is
actually in a very interesting place I
think the thing that separates
individuals from winning is
self-awareness I really do
I I can get across anything in today's
talk it's how do I create some level of
permission for you to start feeling more
comfortable in your own skin in a world
where your mom and dad didn't do that
for you in a world where your
neighbourhood didn't do that for you in
a world where the coolest kid in high
school didn't do that for you in a world
where America makes trillions of dollars
in industries telling you what you suck
[ __ ] at so you've spent money on fixing
it versus doing what is fundamentally
the reason I know I get to stand here on
stage which is you're right Sean I
really don't give a [ __ ] about what
anybody thinks
in the same way rush and Howard thing
the only difference is and I don't know
those guys is I equally really give a
[ __ ] about what you think and I think if
you understand what I mean by that you
can start really tapping through I will
not live my life based on what you want
me to to or whatever the current
politically correct POV is every day and
I know a lot of you know who I am
I get emails yelling at me for my
work-life balance I also know that as
much love as that's and I look at it as
love people email me other things are
trying to hurt my feelings I think
they're telling me things that maybe
happen to them you know hey I have kids
in college now I regret not spending
time with them you're going to and I
don't get mad I just know that that
person doesn't know me I know that
person doesn't know me my friends we're
living in a wiff world not a depth world
there's plenty of my friends that
critique my work life balance that come
home
go downstairs intern mancave drink for
Budweiser's and go to sleep I don't view
them as spending quality time with their
children and so-and-so I'm also very
comfortable in my losses
I'm comfortable in the bed that I made
and thus I sleep in it I'm not perfect I
plan on making mistakes big ones I can't
wait to I have to apologize to America
it's how we roll we're humans right the
fact of the matter is I'm just
comfortable in my intent I'm comfortable
in a lot of things I think for example
I'm comfortable in that most of the
decisions that I've made in my life over
the last 15 to 20 years have been far
more predicated on my legacy than
anything else I've left a lot of money
on the table over the last ten years
because I care about my legacy I want
all of you to show up to my funeral
however I know that I love to reassess
let me explain this year David Bowie
Prince very famous people have passed
away I've been taken aback by the fact
that America cares for about 20 hours
and I've said my god these are really
famous [ __ ] right and we are living
in such a fast-paced world we're moving
on so much quicker and I've sort of said
myself hmm should I care so much about
my legacy that even if I crush it all
the way through if everybody shows up
it's only got a 24 hour window should I
care about my inner circle should I care
about my outer circle I think the
biggest thing that I'm starting to feel
knowing a lot of you have consumed a lot
of my content something that I don't
think I've been sharing a lot that I'd
like to today tonight to bring you guys
value to have you hear something a
little bit different I'm not scared to
fundamentally change my life completely
I am thrilled for making a video that
says [ __ ] hustle thrilled to say this is
my last video for 24 months I'm going on
a beach SIA and 20 29 see what happens
is when you get real comfortable with
yourself you
even care about how you established your
narrative you're willing to break it
because I just don't care about the
repercussions because at that moment I
am comfortable in my decision and my
intent and let me promise you the
quickest way to win and I don't mean
money I mean win playing in a way that
feels right to you before it feels right
to anybody else around you and I promise
you and I promise you that the majority
of you are not what happens just the way
it is it's just the way it is I don't
really know you know it's ironic my wife
plays the same game but I really my mom
maybe let's just it's stunning to me how
few people play it purely that way it's
incredible
how we are affected by the five or six
closest people to us it is incredible -
how many people here in this room right
now that the singular unlock to dramatic
more success emotionally financially and
every other thing you can think of is
actually predicated on them eliminating
one person in their inner circle
normally a family member that is a
complete negative driver and is the
cancer with an eco system does not allow
you to be successful but that's tough
easy for me to say you up here on stage
like kick your mom out of your life
right but here's the punchline it
doesn't make it any less true and so you
know I don't know like there's a million
things we could talk about by the way as
you guys are lining up for Q&A which
fires me up keep doing it I'm thrilled
to answer questions in very specific
detail like how do you make a snapchat
filter or go all the way to what's magic
and so and so and so it's always fun to
speed second and so I that's been on my
mind a lot the other thing that's been
on my mind a ton and I'll go a little
more practical and a little less foofy
here's the punchline my friends it's
called distribution of attention if you
really want to understand what's
happening here all the talks for the
next four days there's only two things
that matter
your content and how many people see it
it's actually a singular binary game of
two things that matter your content and
how many people see it you can listen to
all the people that are going to tell
you how to growth hack or get
distributions or big build lists or run
Facebook ads the best you can listen to
all of that but if the [ __ ] that comes
out of your mouth or what you write on
paper sucks [ __ ] you will lose and the
fact of the matter is over 80% of the
people sitting here aren't talented or
interesting or differentiated enough to
achieve the dollar amounts that they
want that is why I love hustle because
just like I only have so much basketball
DNA and skills if I work really hard I
could be a really fun solid average pick
up player and I have news for some of
you entrepreneurs some of you are just
nice and average entrepreneurs that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't do it
that means that you need to be
self-aware
that if you never made money by the time
you were 25 years old in your life and
you never sold [ __ ] you just might not
be a Salesman got it this game is all
predicated on self-awareness the other
thing that's predicated on is truth the
amount of people sitting in this room
and by the way let me let me define
sitting in this room when I say sitting
in this room actually don't mean the 300
of you actually mean the market so let
me use that and said the amount of
people in the market that claim to be
something they are not because what the
reverse-engineering is that's where the
money is is the biggest reason so many
people lose you just can't fake who you
are you can't manufacture it you can't
want it so many people in here want to
be business coaches and they've never
built a [ __ ] business
before you give me business advice it'd
be really interesting to understand if
you ever made money besides giving
business advice and so that intrigues me
what's more interesting for the
youngsters in this room that want to
play that card is actually documenting
and communicating the journey of
learning business because that's your
truth and so I would tell you the people
that are gonna win are the ones that are
telling the truest story
I'm only lucky and a lot of people get
mad at me when I say I'm lucky they
really do because they do know that I
work hard and there's always that debate
of luck can work and and by the way
losers love to throw out luck but I do
think I'm lucky in the fact that it has
never been more attractive or cooler to
be an entrepreneur than right now it's
so weird I take selfies in the street
because I'm a businessman
the reason I'm really winning is cuz I
was a businessman when it wasn't cool
when I was a loser in school because I
was getting D's and F's and for
everybody here forty to sixty you know
that that was the only your grades were
their narrative of how good you were and
what college you went to was the
narrative of how good you are when I was
getting D's and F's yet making $2,000 a
weekend selling baseball cards my
friends parents and my teachers thought
I was a loser
if I was making two three thousand
dollars a weekend right now as a
thirteen year old in school I'd be the
coolest kid in high school I'd be the
next Mark Zuckerberg I'm gonna be on
Shark Tank one day when I grow up and
everybody would have loved me that's why
it's working for me because I haven't
wavered regardless of what you guys gave
a [ __ ] about and guess what
entrepreneurship is not going to be cool
one day soon too it might be five years
now it might be 10 years from now
when everybody looks down on it because
we should be caring about something else
I'm still gonna be [ __ ] selling [ __ ]
and so and so what I fear right now is
people trying to mold into something
around whatever is convenient right now
or cool you know like your friends that
sold real estate in the mid-2000s and
then we're social media experts when
that market collapse you know that
narrative I'm worried about people that
are following the current trend instead
of following the only thing that they
actually are and that's who wins who do
we cherish and who do we put on pedestal
the people that from the get punted
everything else and when full pledged
themselves LeBron didn't try to become a
well-rounded young man you [ __ ] play
basketball all-in and that's who we look
at Beyonce
there's Home Videos and Star Search and
all that she went all in the people that
we look at and admire they put in the
work from the get regardless of what
they are because that's the only thing
they knew how to be and I'm telling you
right now the best blueprint for your
success is to when you're done tonight
doing whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
tonight to go into your hotel room look
yourself in the mirror and ask yourself
what's the purest form of Who I am
and build a [ __ ] thing around that
that works and whether it's cool right
now or whether it makes the most money
do you think that the best gamers in the
world right now ten years ago thought
sitting in their basement playing
shooter games was going to make them ten
million dollars a year in eSports
absolutely not when you are all in on
your [ __ ] and we now live in a world
where the internet creates niche
communities around every [ __ ] thing
you could ever imagine
that is an unbelievable blessing to all
of us that our grandparents didn't have
an opportunity in and so I just don't
know I know a lot of you have watched a
lot of you tweet about this event I
looked at your accounts people
chasing money I don't give a [ __ ] what
you guys say now I'm talking to this
room most of your chasing [ __ ] money
and you're gonna [ __ ] lose and that's
what I hope you think about I hope you
think about what are you good at or what
are you really a like what's the truest
essence of who you are because those are
the only two things that create the
upside that people chase because I know
people with tons of money that are sad
as [ __ ] right because once you get
something you want the other thing
because it's always grass is greener for
all of us right and so great you unlock
a system you figured out how to do
something and you made some bucks and
then what and so I'm telling you two
things either talent magic which I do
not believe that you can manufacture and
or what the [ __ ] really drives you for
real and maybe it won't make so much
money right now but when you deploy the
tactics of snapchat and Facebook ads and
AR and pokemons go and whatever you
deploy the tactics against if you're
deploying it against fake [ __ ] that's
being built just to make a dollar
you're gonna lose over time you're not
going to be able to sustain you know why
I hustle cuz I [ __ ] love it you know
why I hustle cuz it's my oxygen you know
why I hustle because I don't even know
what the [ __ ] else to do this is what I
do and if like if you really think about
what would you do every MIT like what
I'm retired now like when people say
they're gonna retire and play golf and
surf great I'm doing that now if you ask
me to golf
I rip my [ __ ] arm off I'd be so
pissed like I don't want to lay on a
beach my head's turning I want to do
[ __ ] I want to make [ __ ] I want to talk
to you I want to live this is how I live
the people that hustle the most are the
happiest not the saddest thank you
and and you know what I'm even disgusted
in my own Rara just now in a practical
level it is practical to make money
around the thing that interests you the
most it's amazing even Oh crush it is
the furthest thing from what I've done
in this space it's still the truest we
live in an Internet age where niches are
long and deep and you can make money
doing anything and the thing you'll make
the most money on is the thing you like
the most because it the thing you like
the most will allow you the work the
hardest and that will be the variable of
success and if you love it so much
you'll also research it more because it
was what you'd naturally do anyway in
your free time and then you'll work
harder and then you'll make money not
you're a [ __ ] life coach my man
don't you name Alexander what's that
Alexander love it yeah thank you Gary
appreciate it
I was actually thing about create a
shirt that just says I love it so many
people yeah do i bad here's what's up
yeah all right good go closer no wait he
[ __ ] better there we go all right so
you know once you find out who you are
and your strategy and all of that I'm
real quick go ahead
most people [ __ ] die before they
figure out who that you they are this is
sure like before we all go like okay now
you think like like real quick like
before you figure out who you are like
once you figure out who you are just to
give you a quick punchline most of you
haven't gotten there yet everybody's
talking about the tactics what about the
religion like figuring out who you are
especially at this young of an age
challenge challenge you've been told who
you are most of your life so going in
that cocoon by yourself and figuring it
out and blocking out everything that's
[ __ ] hard so I'll answer your
question but I promise you that's not so
simple and and honestly that's what's
happening in this space too much
everybody's going to step two and I
haven't even started on step one go
ahead
thank you spot on almost read my mind so
what I'm talking about is I know I truly
believe that I have found out who I am
what you know there's so many
distractions so many snapchats I could
watch your snapchat I could watch Ty's I
could watch you know everybody snapchat
right so many distractions so many
things my question is once you figure
out who you are in the vision that you
want to go how do you not stay you're
talking about distribution of attention
how do you go about staying on that one
buying the Jets whether the case may be
for you Dan Martell you know Shawn I've
never watched a six
Shawn's video spoof of Wine Library TV
which is phenom it up for that for the
people to saw this [ __ ] humble
that's literally Josh right there all
these cool homies I've never watched a
single piece of content come out of
Dan's [ __ ] mouth I'm being dead
serious
I don't know how do I I've never been
distracted because I don't give a [ __ ]
what anybody else is talking about I'm
worried about my [ __ ] so if you're
[ __ ] watching everybody
snaps maybe you're just not as ribbon as
I am maybe you don't care about the
things that I care about you know what I
care about how everybody here reacts to
content so I spent all my time reading
all your comments I know everything
you've said about everything that I've
done because it's what I used to figure
out what I'm gonna do next so instead of
watching Sean's point of view or [ __ ]
Wes who loves to claim he's a better
speaker than me and he [ __ ] sucks
you know like you know you know instead
of doing that dumb [ __ ] I'm paying
attention that when I put out content
how do you guys actually respond to it
because that's what makes me a front
leader I don't give a [ __ ] about Guy
Kawasaki or Seth Godin point of view on
musically I'm gonna go and use it watch
how you guys react to it and then that's
why people listen to me because I do it
first because I don't even consume it
anybody else's content so my [ __ ] stays
pure and my [ __ ] is pure because you're
actually giving me the feedback cuz
you're actually the audience so for me
it's a waste of [ __ ] time I got time
to watch the New York Jets
that's my escapism other than that
family and this [ __ ]
I you're asking the wrong person how to
tune out other [ __ ] cuz I don't care
I haven't read anybody's [ __ ] book
does good answer it's the truth
excellent thanks for doing sex oh by the
way out out out dinner by the way Alice
by the way that's not necessarily right
for you there's a lot of people here
that do learn from watching other people
[ __ ] my answer is I know myself I got
D's and F's for a reason I'd love to
read everybody's wonderful books here
I just won't retain any of the
information that's the ultimate waste of
[ __ ] time if you're getting value by
watching others and that helps your game
that's the way you need to roll my game
is based on me knowing myself and that's
how I get good that's not disrespect to
all these wonderful people
that's me understanding how I learn you
got it
and it's great seeing you I saw you last
year at thrive so it was great talking
to you then so one of the things that I
that I constantly see or that you always
mentioned on your on your podcast or
your snapchats is definitely always
about the uber deal being something that
you didn't get into early on the reason
I bring up passing on uber twice's
everybody always wants me to talk about
my failures and the [ __ ] is I don't know
most of them that's one that I know so I
bring it up got it and then as far as as
far as when it when it goes to into that
into that aspect with with new business
opportunities what is something that it
is that you see on either the founders
of the team that really make you want to
jump on it I mean uber was a somewhat of
a pretty big starting up but what was it
I mean what do you want to see in a
business before it before you see it
take traction and actually become
involved in it what do I need to see if
for me to invest in something there
it's normally intuition they have it has
to be two things one do I believe in the
space so right now I believe in
meditation right so I think consumer
meditation is going to be huge so then
when I look at the headspace founders or
the comm founders I need to understand
the jockey so the only thing I do is I
always have a thesis do I believe that
Americans the world are going to use
this product right are we gonna behave
that way , do I believe in these
founders are capable of being the people
that win in that game that's it nothing
else
I don't care your app has seven billion
people if I don't think that's where the
world's going to be in three or four
years I'm out and I don't care that I
totally believe in meditation if you
pitch it to me and you've never sold
anything and you have no wins on your
table and I don't feel anything
intuitively you have no shot either so
that's how I basically make decisions
that make sense and then as far as the
founders that you have worked with what
is it that you saw in them and no clue
you're into ash it's like falling in
love no idea excellent you know what I
mean like [ __ ] I don't know you know
and people and founders come in and try
to tell me [ __ ] they know I'll hear like
I hustled when I was a kid you know I'm
like you're a [ __ ] liar next you know
it's intuition sense yeah perfect Thanks
you got it
hi Gary I'm Susie hey Susie amazing to
meet you thank you I first saw your
video back in like 2010 The Smurfs it up
one so first of all I want to say thank
you seriously from the bottom of my
heart for like every single video
everything that you do I think I speak
collectively for everyone but you
inspire us so much thank you so much um
I also came from an immigrant family so
I'd like so much respect for what your
family is built and you and your family
right however I'm the only entrepreneur
in my family and so my question is more
about like I fought through being like
the black sheep and doing something
different than everyone else because
everybody wanted you to go to education
and that doctor lawyers that abortion
yeah yeah like do the safe thing because
they're like terrified of doing
different so I'd like fought through
that I've actually built up my business
in the last two years to run thank you
so the question becomes now how do i up
level my environment right like you were
talking about how those closest five
people it may be like a limiting
eliminating one of them and that was I
don't know kind of interesting like how
do I up love all the people that I spend
time with and when everyone around you
kind of operates in fear you know what I
mean like how do you up level that whole
environment
by going out and hanging out with those
kind of people how do you do that like
honestly if you work from hugely by
taking an uber or a flight
on a day-to-day basis on an indonesian
basis i look you can't control your
family right my dad is one of the most
negative people i know like if this
whole room was filled with water my dad
would say this is half glass empty my
dad is super negative but I love my dad
the most and I spend time with him but
you know you can't control your family
you can control your friends so if
you've got a family that you think is
dragging you down or looks down at what
you're doing but you love them and I
love you know my sister is pretty
negative I love her the most she's my
baby sister I want to hang with her all
the time I would tell you that if you've
got a situation where all of them
because my mom's super positive AJ's
been kind of more neutral upper positive
I would say that you've got to really be
very conscious of your friends and what
you have around you besides your family
and I would go extreme positive in that
direction you know I mean you can only
control so much right and like I think
we all have family may think for anybody
here to have zero family members that
are negative it's just my sister
believed my dad more than she believed
my mom that she became more negative
later in her life very recently she's
kind of flipped and it's been
game-changing I think it's some level
you choose it's unbelievable the level
of disrespect I have for everybody
else's opinion and I think that you
should consider to try that too
I mean it and it's very helpful for me
by the way I think the right a lot of
times I don't think I'm always right but
I'm gonna tell you something right now
I'm always right for me and that's a
very subtle difference I'm not always
right but I'm a hundred percent for me
you know I'm always right for me and
that's it and so I think it's the
friends and I think it's deploying a
little less credence and belief in what
your family is saying I would start
disrespecting them aggressively hey guys
good it's going super well man how are
you good
quick question uh McGuire rookie card
yeah USA Olympic should I just sell it
or will the world forget that he did
steroids and had the homerun record
during dinner um yeah like shitty did
you get it graded uh yeah it's mint I
really five probably wait for him to
like you know it's kind of like all the
kids that were smart to sit on their
pokemon cards and just sell it now
there's nothing good going on with
McGuire's brand right now I'd wait for
the next bump hopefully getting a look
into the Hall of Fame once everybody
forgets and liquidate then cool cast my
real question now yeah all right so I
spent 16 years building a very
successful building business sorry very
successful business and I coach in that
business and I absolutely hate it it
just it drives me nuts you have a
business that you've spent six years on
1616 that's super successful yeah you
hate it but I hate it
right sounds like a losing formula yeah
it sucks so I'm trying to figure out how
I can find out you know what I coach
very nishan that in that market how I
can somehow test those skills out to a
broader market you know maybe go just
for you see it's a little tough for me
to hear I've gotta go to ear - sorry
that's better better are you telling you
you say you're coaching in that business
yeah I still work in that business I
coaching that business I'm trying to
figure out if I can use those skills to
go broader instead of so deep in a niche
niche and I I don't know what platform
to test that out on your message you
mean yeah as a gateway drug to people we
didn't want to continue to coach right
are you sure about that
yes
absolutely I enjoy the coaching aspect
of it I'm just sick of this particular
industry
well then everywhere like how do you
communicate best written audio video
facebook video probably yeah like
pollute your own waters don't forget
you're talking to a dude that everybody
thought was the wine guy and had no idea
why the [ __ ] he started talking about
business right right so I think what
people do when they try to change is
they're worried that that audience
doesn't want to hear that
I'm sure ninety-four percent of my white
audience didn't want to hear about
social media strategy but the six
percent that did was the base that built
the next thing cool thank you welcome hi
Gary
get into that mic okay can you hear me
great okay
so I've spent the last 10 years building
a household staffing agency so I help
families basically around the world you
know get half household staff and my
question for you is I've built my
business where I'm kind of it I want to
kind of go to the next level
I've been content with the level I've
been at weight real quick when you say
the next level define me to me what that
means for you to hire I guess another
one of me somebody that had to pay very
well to also deal with the clients and
kind of manage them then you don't want
it all on you I don't want it all on me
you know because it's like I'm the one
getting late and I calls and things like
that I'm trying to work on the work-life
balance and so why haven't you done it
so far I've had I had a really good
assistant for a long time handle it and
I made the mistakes she got it got a job
offer to start up doing something she
was really meant to do and since then I
felt like
assistants and people working for me are
not at that level like their great
earlier you made a mistake no okay I
didn't hear right sure but I thought you
said you made a mistake but maybe not
matching it she just went on to go do
something else
yeah exactly so that that was okay and
since then you haven't been able to find
somebody as strong yeah I stopped
looking for a while because the clients
that they would call would they would
just be I want to talk to Brooke my
clientele is a little different in that
they're all like millionaires and
billionaires and they don't respond to
typical marketing and my question for
you is kind of especially to double my
business and kind of afford another one
of me I was wondering if you might have
an idea or two something maybe I haven't
thought of so you're saying to me you're
trying to reach high net worth
individuals because you're staffing you
know services within their home if you
have to afford that you've got to be
rich yeah your plan is that you want to
make more money you want to get more
clients and then with that money you can
get another you exactly let me ask you a
question differently okay are you making
enough money right now to have another
one of you because my intuition is you
can it's just you want to have a certain
amount of take home or spend that money
on some other stuff yeah that's true
I mean another one of me but a cheaper
yeah not super cheap not like minimum
wage but not where that like super
motivated you you're about to walk into
a hamster wheel that you're gonna lose
and most solo entrepreneurs lose which
is you're gonna try to double revenue to
deploy against you because you want to
maintain your take-home income and not
invest in your business tomorrow you
should pay you should figure out how
much money you have to take how much
when you take home what's the least you
can take home and still live your life
and what I mean live your life I mean
pay your bills and I think you should go
hire somebody have one year where you
didn't take the best vacations you ever
[ __ ] took and you didn't buy the best
[ __ ] you ever bought and then have that
person and then that person with you
will build up that revenue so many of
you want both you want to take home
money to buy [ __ ] and you want your
business to grow businesses grow
when you invest in your [ __ ] business
and that's about it it's so common I see
it every day
the reason I built Wine Library so fast
is I was willing to as a young man when
I was 28 years old have a $40,000 a year
salary while all my other friends were
had nice things
I built a 40 million dollar business and
I wasn't reaping any of the benefits
because every [ __ ] penny was going
back in because I was fine to reap the
benefits when I was 29 39 and 69 right
yeah I think what you need to do is take
your number all the way down and be able
to deploy that against people because
then the combo of you guys will build a
top-line revenue and you'll get it back
within 24 months yeah patience okay
patience is the killer patience is the
absolute thing that most people don't
deploy into their business and that
limits their growth do you have like one
unique idea you can share yeah you
should make Facebook video and targeted
against high net worth individuals cuz
they're there yeah they're okay
video video paint a picture to them okay
have you ever gone on vacation wish
somebody did a better job for you right
like are you pissed when you're you know
house cleaner calls out up yeah got it
yeah thank you you got it hello Gary
hello I love the show thank you and my
name is Rachel Luna Rachel Luna thopas
let's have everybody alright so lately
you have had some killer guests on the
show and I'm wondering what's the
strategy behind who you're bringing you
know as get super I have people reaching
out to me just randoms yes
Fredrik for the real estate show wants
to be on the show I know who he is
um I do well with real estate agents I'm
like okay Fat Joe [ __ ] yeah
you know so super duper random no real
strategy other than when you have famous
people on the show you mark it against
their fan base on platforms it brings
awareness to me it's interesting content
I needed a period of mixing it up it was
just me now I don't want any [ __ ]
guests ever again I'm back to wine to me
and so that's you know I'm a
counter-puncher by Nature
I am one course strategy where is
attention that most people are under
estimating musically I want every eight
to 15 year old kid in America to look up
to me as the entrepreneur for them so if
I get them at eight and seven and nine
I'll have them so while everybody's like
musically stupid I'm like that's great
but every 1st to 5th grader in America
lives on it and here comes old man Gary
as their favorite entrepreneur got it
let me throw this at you though it just
has a little bounce back look so here's
back yeah I like that so you're saying
you mix it up how did how do you mix it
up when you're also trying to keep your
head in the game and just do that one
thing really really well talent well I'm
[ __ ] talented I got your minutes
watch me thank you see because you know
the best part about talent yes is we can
all talk [ __ ] yeah the results are the
[ __ ] game okay what's your what why
are you measuring those results money Oh
freedom okay
happiness okay money happy freedom you
know I don't know like how many selfies
I take a day I don't know like like you
know I think we get to all measure it
differently right right and so I'm you
don't need people in here or all about
math conversions and quantum you know
what that's called that's called sales
people marketing and branding doesn't
[ __ ] get measured by the hour all
right Thanks so for me how do I measure
it is how do I feel about where I'm
positioned you know how am i how am i
equally you know vaynermedia is gonna do
a hundred million dollars in revenue
this year and it's scaled it's not the
Gary Vaynerchuk consulting firm I don't
[ __ ] deal with any clients I'm the
CEO I hire people I do all myself some
of you seen the last couple episodes I'm
dealing with my HR stuff like I'm
running a company I run a hundred
million dollar Madison Avenue agency and
in parallel Gary Vee is my side hustle
you want to feel real bad Gary Vee is my
side hustle
I'm an entrepreneur CEO of an agency I
run the actual business so for me how do
I measure it how well as vain are doing
right
how well is my speaking request coming
in how many people are watching my stuff
but I don't measure it on a tactical
day-to-day it's an overall feeling of a
vibe intuition and some baseline metrics
that I mean I never look at any of my
data like I can see it publicly I can
see if 10,000 people like this photo I'm
like oh [ __ ]
people like this Instagram photo I look
at it but like I don't know seems like
the same old [ __ ] but anyway you know
like like you know I think a lot of
people are so into landing page
optimization elite that [ __ ] works
but that's sales and when you're great
brand they didn't cookie me and then
retarget me and I get me on a list and
then convert and a/b test me and funnel
me and then go make a deal with another
company and JV their lists for each
other and all that [ __ ] horseshit
they branded me people didn't come here
just to see me speak because I cookie
them and raid on Facebook ad it's
because I provided so much [ __ ] value
they wanted to see it in person branding
thank you
all right get dressed Gary hi I'm Jean I
don't think you suffer from this based
on what we can see about you and the
real world could be surprised I could be
surprised but I've been working on this
concept around a book for a little while
Laurette what a book you want to write a
book yeah I'm ready you're writing a
book I'm actually will finish the book
you finished the book Oh back up okay
mister hustle I will finish the book one
day July 31st first draft okay right
I still got a more I got things to do
back for that so the concept is I've
been talking I go to live events all the
time I speak on stages got a podcast
interviewing hundreds of people it's
called the trap of success the trap of
success yeah because there's a point at
which you will get in success and they
play safe
yeah you talked a little bit about
significance and about some of the stuff
you do and the book is really centered
around that I'd love your perspective on
that and what you see in your circles
and because you interact with so many
people around the notion of like where
he's holding golden handcuffs versus it
could be golden handcuffs I mean I it's
my personal story part of it because I
had a very successful business and I
wanted to innovate I was making you know
five hundred thousand a year or
something like that and I had lifestyle
and I said I don't want to lose that I
get it to go really make something that
wouldn't change my life and change the
life of everyone else yeah I played
[ __ ] safe yep because I was afraid to
lose it all
that's right and you can probably guess
what happened yeah I mean it's not fun
like it's the same old story I think
that um I think we all go through
journeys one thing that I would tell you
it's funny where my head went when you
started talking I think a lot about
regret I think one of the most
interesting thing about spending time
with old people is regret if you talk to
80 and 90 year olds the place where
their face really changes is when they
talk about what they didn't do or what
they wish they did that here's the
punchline when you get to that age and
you're in a retirement home or do not
move it's over
and you know it a lot of us still live
on we can still like everything we're
upset about right now the majority of us
99% of us can still do something about
it and that hope drives us so you know
it's interesting it's a really
interesting question you're right I'm a
little weird I'm a little weird I don't
know if you ever caught this I don't
talk about it often i weirdly fantasize
of losing everything I think I exactly
heard you said I wish I would I because
I can build it back yeah cuz to me
I love the build yeah like like I think
the reason I started Vayner sports
sports this sports agency is cuz
everybody thinks it's a joke that is
like Drew Rosenhaus and CIA and rock
nation and I'm gonna [ __ ] slice their
throats right like to me I love that I
love the underdog like I hated Tiger
Woods then America started hitting him
now I like him because of finished you
know I hated Kobe but then when he got
old oh my god yeah Kobe you know like so
I love the underdog I love the climb so
for me I'm very reverse like I love my
vacations before I get there in a second
I land on the plane I start getting
upset right I live for anticipation and
the climb so I don't think I'm the best
person to give advice around golden
handcuffs I'm only comfortable putting
the chips in changing it what do you see
from others what's that
what do you see from others because
you're asking from others people
thinking short-term yeah like you know
how long you're gonna live when I hear
35 year olds tell me they're golden
handcuff them like you're what are you
talking about and and and it goes back
to the lovely lady that was right before
you like like people want stuff like I
don't like you know your lifestyle what
was that right like is it the house is
that the country club is that the car is
it the trips like relay services all of
it yeah it's a comet-like to me it's
unbelievable so what I see in others you
know the answer is I don't need to
pontificate on it I'm just grateful and
thankful that I don't have it and I and
I always wonder how much of that has to
do with the same thing I started this
with which is I definitely don't need it
for others I think one of the things
that's fascinated me in others is they
need the car and the watch
and the trophy husband or wife because
they want other people to see it I mean
this is why I pound everybody to love
themselves first I don't need that I
don't want that I don't care I love it
it's fine I like the accolades I like
the attention I like the attention
because of what I put out I like the
people take selfies with firm with me
not because I score 41 points a night in
an arena but because I'm putting out so
much good content that brings them value
they're thankful so when I think about
significance I think about all the money
I leave on the table every day to do the
garyvee side hustle thing you know my
other billionaire friends that build
businesses always are weirded out by me
they're like why aren't you wasting your
time with that and I'm like I'm like
part of its vanity I like the admiration
but I tell them all the time I'm like
look yeah you may end up with 940
million and I may end up with 297
million but a lot more people are going
to show up at my funeral a lot more
people like me a lot more people are
gonna say nice things about me to my
kids than they are about you and that's
more important to me yeah I'll tell you
the reason you said a word I haven't
thought of in the cause it's helped me
with a book little louder that you said
regret yes and I hadn't thought about
this but the reason I'm writing the book
is it because my own regret yep and it's
because I had that chance to do
something big
yep and I [ __ ] it off here's the
coolest part bro how old are you 45 you
have a fuckload more at-bats
I will never retire that's fine right
like you can do 87 more big things yeah
like you may save somebody from getting
hit by a truck in four years like
there's so much to be done little and
big you know but the reason I'm writing
is because the regret and I'm helping
p.m. with my business now I'm helping
people see what I didn't see I get it
and so that they can build that business
they can get it that chance I get it
build that huge thing
I understand get out of their own [ __ ]
way agree it get uncomfortable yep and
invest in themselves all that oh that
so thanks for your exotic understood my
man alright I'm gonna start going a
little faster sure we gotta get this
baby very [ __ ] B what is up
dude what's up man dude this is so
amazing
I've been following you for now for you
actually that USC video that you did and
I just took off I don't I'm sure you
know that yes but that actually what is
what got me up on you man and uh you
know it's been fantastic I've been an
entrepreneur since 2006 I'm a coffee guy
I do coffee I know you like coffee yep
rock and roll Roasters coffee in case
anybody cares ah I'm sure so many of you
guys do way anyways uh I started in 2009
I opened my first shop brick-and-mortar
I have seven locations now and it wasn't
easy right 2008 2009 2010 man I bought a
coffee roaster on Craigslist it was like
four pennies because everybody was
selling everything for cheap yep um it
was hard it was hard a lot a lot of
anxiety a lot of you know bankruptcy was
looming man it was crazy it was intense
it was difficult those first few years
were insane nowadays it's almost too
easy to be an entrepreneur right yeah
it's almost too easy
it's not easy it will this well that why
are you talking about people getting
funding yeah well they're gonna lose
exactly it's exactly exactly what I do
real quick yep it's easy to say you're
an entrepreneur yeah is it easy to be a
successful entrepreneur for sure it's
not right so so the question is then
what do you see happening in the next 1
to 3 years down the road because right
now the last seven years man it's been
up yeah look what do you see happening
though because I don't know because what
you're asking is when does the economy
shift and that has a lot more to do what
those characters on Wall Street are is
up to shenanigans and whenever the [ __ ]
falls out from underneath it I don't
know but here's what I can tell you the
world has proven to us a whole bunch of
times that it goes up and it goes
right right I just don't know the timing
and I think I think if you're asking
with the purpose of I want to be
prepared I think I live my life that I'm
prepared for [ __ ] to hit the wall every
day every day I anticipate that I'm
gonna wake up and it's Armageddon I love
it and so I would tell you if I
understand where the energy is coming
from never overextend yourself and hold
your breath that shit's gonna still be
good for a year because not me not
anybody's going to answer that for you
what you need to do is make pretend
tomorrow everything is going to be
[ __ ] and are you able to take that
punch in the mouth it's funny my
favorite scene in every movie is that
part where the person gets punched in
the mouth and they like spit their tooth
out and then look back at the person I
love that moment because that's who I
think I am as an entrepreneur like I
want bad I'll be very honest with you I
hope it comes tomorrow because the
quicker it happens the quicker all you
fake entrepreneurs are gonna get the
[ __ ] out of this game Thank You Man
perfect got it hey guys in an effort to
get through as many questions as
possible if we could keep some of the
backstory to a minimum just ask the
question for Gary we'd love to hear the
answer to get get to the question that'd
be great
hey Gary I'm Jeremy hey man and I had a
question for you about with the advent
of social media and we
there seems to be this training network
everybody even offer is an entrepreneur
that's right what this is you're almost
around what pisses me off what what this
is you almost man that contract I just
feel bad for people like you know I feel
bad it doesn't you know pisses me off in
a weird way but since you asked me what
pisses me off I'm gonna go the other way
I have I'm empathetic I feel really bad
for all the people that are writing
$25,000 checks and are gonna lose that
money they fought hard to get it and
they're putting into some kid because
they think they're the next Mark
Zuckerberg and they're gonna get [ __ ]
I feel bad for a bunch of kids that have
been told that entrepreneurship is cool
and they want to be in it where they
could have went and worked at a law firm
or worked at Bain in McKinsey and made a
lot of money and work naturally
themselves you know I mean you know much
more money number 13 made at Facebook
the number one of Facebook and so you
know what upsets me is that the
narrative is that it's so easy back to
the last question that guy right like
it's easy to say your founder it's a lot
harder to do it five years from today
and so I'm more worried than I am pissed
off I'm worried about suicide there's a
merge there's a rise in depression and
suicide in entrepreneur land because for
some reason everybody thinks that you're
successful when you start a business and
you have a lot of Ivy League school kids
who've always had a big game of success
you know I always say daddy can't buy a
library in the market the market the
business world can't be bought and so
we've got a lot of people going into
entrepreneurship that aren't wired for
it and their outlet to fix it is quite
negative sometimes the most extreme put
pen a great school with a lot of
entrepreneurial DNA has seen a
significant rise in suicide and it's
predicated on everybody thinking that
think they're gonna be Travis or sucks
so I'm worried more for people than I am
pissed for the game of entrepreneurship
you know and there seems to be and I've
a lot of my podcast there seems to be
this missing link between when they
started and when they got successful
they leave out all the negative [ __ ]
just go from I started here and here's
all the money yeah that's why I always
like talking about hustle everyone's
like uh you know like people love to
like you know at conferences I'm at or
when they use my name to get traffic for
their website they're like no you don't
have to do that you can do it so awesome
and I passive income and all the [ __ ]
and so like you know like it's it's
[ __ ] very hard guys do you know what
the top 1% of earners in America what
the bottom number is of a top 1% earner
at the entry point into the 1% it's
$400,000 for if you may if you're
sitting here and you make $400,000 or
more you and the 1% earners in America
do you know how outrageously successful
that is but some people that don't make
a million a year or like oh I'm not good
like it's crazy the way we built up this
game it's crazy we need to reframe
entrepreneurship right entrepreneurship
to me is you can't breathe doing
anything else there was no work even
that last guy I love that guy
because he's given me a lot of love and
he had a great vibe I love when he said
I've been an entrepreneur since oh six
and when he said that I said in my mind
either you're not an entrepreneur or you
were an entrepreneur from the get your
eat this binary entrepreneurship is not
a profession it's what you are you know
so yeah thank you you got it my man with
the kicks yeah yeah hey Gary Kevin
Stimson here so I own
brand name creativity great and so we're
all operating memorable disruptive and
bad experience okay the one thing that I
stand against is that most online
businesses can care less about being
memorable disruptive and badass they
would do the same exact thing as
everybody else they value clicks and I
yes so what I wonder is I want to hear
how you would communicate the ROI of a
brand and like what that means to you
you mean the biggest companies in the
world yes what is more money you can get
it it's why I don't talk about
conversion and landing page optimization
and email conversion and funnels and
[ __ ] like that because there's plenty of
people talking about sales I talk about
brand branding is putting out the best
story putting out content that brings
value brand is you can't explain it but
you know it when you see it right and so
I always tell people Apple is a terrible
advertiser they're just a great [ __ ]
brand but I a Polly I love when homies
in this world and most of the people
here are converters and math and quant
when they like talk [ __ ] about the
biggest brands in the world doing bad
you know like they're like oh look how
silly that ad is or they didn't do their
SEO proper I'm like Rick do you
understand you're talking about that
like you know yes all of us are not as
strong at every tactic but how do I
describe brand and what it means I
explained it by listing the 500 biggest
companies in the world the coolest
people in the world the people that are
winning and the companies that are
winning and I talk about brand and then
I talk about things that have lost
because they were conversion based
machines Zynga LivingSocial there's
people that are way better at math than
you are and so if marketing was math my
friends this [ __ ] would have been over a
long time ago now I don't want to
disrespect the math we live in a digital
age where the math and the conversion of
landing page opposition it matters but
if you don't layer something pure and
good or awesome or
what you're talking about on top of it
you can only hit a certain level and
that's okay you knowing people here
don't give a [ __ ] about what you and I
talk about Brandon pump to making a
million dollars a year on quant
conversion landing page optimization
the problem is here's my brand's awesome
when brand converts from desktop landing
page optimization to a mobile device
brand goes there the people in here that
lived and died on that conversion use
when when Google changes an algorithm
right brand survives people that did SEO
farming lost got it when this all goes
to when this all goes to V our brands
coming but you're gonna have to figure
out how to survive when we don't have
clicks and conversions and it's all
virtual in ten years all of you ready
for ten years from now when it's going
to be brand not conversion based SEO and
quant magic that's brand my dog by the
way that was a really important part of
this conference if you're relying on
internet marketing arbitrage you need to
be prepared for the next decade because
a lot of transformations are coming and
you don't want to be one-dimensional
just relying on that one arbitrage on
that JV on that landing page on that
Facebook ad on that SCM strategy you've
got to be prepared hi Gary
my name is Mikey Rashi how are you you
got great coaches Mike listening I love
you your own online
how I think think you are thank you
brother is that before the most
important thing to me which is why well
because you always preach it is robbing
yourself so I know if I love myself
truthful y'all be a better businessman a
better person but a hundred percent so I
work on that bus with you is some tips
on how I could do that better and more
sometimes I do it amazing sometimes I'm
struggling and keep the people that say
good things about you close back to the
first question today but you know I'll
be honest with you it's very interesting
in the way I'm going about it right my
mom did it for me
now I'm having you guys do it for me
like I read the good [ __ ] you know how
many of you have heard me say your
comments are my oxygen raise your hand
that's it so you know great friend once
I surround myself with great friends
where if that's it if there's a role to
have down days like you just try to make
more good ones than bad ones but having
a community and reread nice things about
you like I love giving you so much is
when you email me back and say nice
things or you give me good energy or you
know I need that that's my oxygen so I
have to stay positive and the other
thing is I cut negativity out the reason
so a lot of you how many of you seen the
last two dailyvees where I've been doing
the culture I think one of it it's funny
a lot of you have been women a lot of
you are not watching it [ __ ] that's a um
a lot of people been hitting me up and
go Gary I can help you with all your
problems they don't realize our culture
is phenomenal Jerry you when you office
the other day it's [ __ ] Happyland it's
just I have [ __ ] I have [ __ ] such a
high standard that I want zero citizens
in the negativity so I just continue to
cut that cancer out so it's coming from
myself
well that was instilled in you brother
yeah it was so how do I be by cutting
more of it out and adding more good in
every day I'm doing this every day I'm
[ __ ] doing this I'm pushing anything
negative out and I'm bringing everything
good in every day and every day I'm
getting [ __ ] got it that's it the
[ __ ] that went in you in the get you're
not going to get that out by what you do
now you can't dwell that it got there
you know many people are losing cuz you
do well my friends stop [ __ ] dwelling
nobody gives a [ __ ] you can't do well
I'm sorry that you grew up in a bad
neighborhood I'm sorry that you're a
minority I'm sorry that this bad thing
happened nobody gives a [ __ ] so cut your
dwelling out and start looking at good
let me give you one really great thing
you're a human being
dunno [ __ ] insane that is for all
your math [ __ ] nerds look at that
[ __ ] math it's hard and so so that's
what you have to do thank you
you got it hi Gary
hey Sheila um speaking of Wall Street
earlier I teach people how to I teach
people how to create an income in the
stock market and Bill financially so
they can quit their 95 when I think in
this industry there's such a negative
stigma yes
like I hate wall space more than Hitler
yeah but what is your advice for getting
past that stigma to my audience and also
tell the people on Wall Street to stop
[ __ ] around like you're not gonna be
able to get them past that stigma yeah
like I know 50 guys and gals on Wall
Street right now we're telling me to my
face that they're doing the dirty
business that they did that not their
job boy I'm teaching people do I teach
them to do this for themselves don't
okay
give your [ __ ] money the problem is
the people that are [ __ ] digging the
game when your [ __ ] hits the fan all
your people that did it nice by
themselves with me of [ __ ] when the
market gets cut in half depending on how
you do it here's what I know
100% of the people lose when the market
loses 50% of its net worth overnight
right like when you have those the only
thing that's happened you know this I
know you know this if you look at the
patterns over the last two decades you
know exactly what happens next these
markets are naturally faintly being
inflated which is why we're gonna have
dramatic drops and that's why you learn
how to trade good options and make money
on the day
Oh listen this fact then you can shorten
I understand how you can bet against it
but what I would say to you is what I
always tell people is there's no
marketing in the world people come to me
all the time and I go look I could be
the great if if I am or if I was or if I
spire to be there's no great marketing
that fixes a [ __ ] product right so how
do you get people to stop looking at the
market negatively you won't because the
narrative will stay there what you can
do is educate them and this is really a
very big point you need to change the
script you need to tell them that people
looking at the market in a negative way
is the opportunity okay do you I'm going
the fact of smart guys like me don't
want to [ __ ] around with it is their
opportunity okay and how do I get past
the like when I look out there at others
that are in the industry
I see the stacks of cash and the
half-naked ladies and the yachts and
that's not what I'm trying that's not
the picture I'm trying to paint so don't
mean to it but that's what you're
talking to me I [ __ ] hate every
single person that's in marketing if
their [ __ ] [ __ ] rent like [ __ ] I
don't want to get into this like the
Instagram culture of this horseshit is
the worst I just you know I hate it but
I never gate through it I mean you're
not gonna stop people selling people to
[ __ ] dream yeah what you need to do
is be an anomaly within it okay all
right all right awesome
you got it hey gay
in episode 202 of the show I asked you
how wrong you took to celebrate your win
of this crush in this last book launch
and your answer was none he said he said
you suck at celebrating I do then you
want if ik ated on that you need to
actually do more of it yes I'm just
super curious if you have since thought
of that and if your where where you're
going with your celebration because
that's having something that you realize
that something I need to do but yeah it
was just a yep in there gaming so since
that episode I remember that very
clearly I've done nothing good I've I've
celebrated nothing and I haven't been
able to move the needle whatsoever
awesome great what are you gonna do to
fix that if any you know I just think
it's look it's in the same way it's back
to the talent conversation right it's
like there's certain things that are
hardwired in us and I'd like to be
better at it it seems fun to celebrate
um I just I just said more comfortable
in the climb that's one thing that I
wondered after is is it that you need to
celebrate is that really that you want
us to think you need to learn how to do
or is this yeah yeah yeah I think so
like I think you got it I think the way
it the whole thing is the celebration
for me you know what I mean yeah like
I'm just so grateful I mean guys for all
of you like to have people admire you
enough to want to take a picture with
you or sit here and listen to you like I
wish you and I have a feeling a lot of
you have this and we all have different
versions of it plenty people have more
to me plenty love less the feeling that
other human beings value what comes out
of your mouth and like you is so intense
like there's no dollar amount like if I
don't make another dollar in my life I
already made a [ __ ] mark like it's the
money is great and I want it and do I
want to buy the Jets of course if you
know me best you know I want to try to
buy the Jets that's the part that is my
drive I I made a video already I'll
share it here there's a video of me that
I would share with the world
that proclaims that this day is the
worst day of my life
and I'm gonna run it the day I buy the
Jets because then that part is over and
I'm glad I made such a lofty goal you
know how many of you in don't [ __ ]
this is a very interesting insight and
it's not pro or con so don't be scared
but I want to see the number how many of
you have already surpassed the financial
or success goal you had for yourself in
your kind of teenage early years raise
your hand I figure it's gonna be a lot
and like that's awesome and that's
[ __ ] the best right but like the way
I'm wired I'm so grateful that I made
even subconsciously in fourth grade I
knew myself I made something so [ __ ]
big that I get to play every day even in
my monstrous success so I think you got
it thank you thanks brother one more
I'll sneak in I said time one more guy
gets it so marry a red person in 2009
thank you so much both the full time
income on YouTube and I love doing that
but it's super passion about speaking
doing podcast like you're talking about
something you'd like to figure out a lot
of value to people here what are your
tag is and I just want to transition
into teaching the how high you knitted
and speaking so what are the tactics if
you want to transition into getting paid
to speak correct speak for free a lot
awesome thank you this is and that's it
like like do you know what I did in 2006
I found a site I think it was tech mean
at the time that had a list of all the
conference's right and I just went to
the websites of all those conferences
and I emailed them and said I'd like to
speak and most of them said who the [ __ ]
are you and I said you're worse than and
I was like I don't know like me this is
me right the number one thing you should
do is speak for free so many people are
fancy my friend so many people are fancy
you want something fight for it that's
why you can fight for it is go around
and do it for free
build up a resume put those talks on
your website build momentum maybe I had
no clue that I was a good public speaker
I was 32 years old for some I ever gave
a talk have no
you may be great at it if you're doing
YouTube full-time like you might have
that story so just do as many gigs for
free as possible and never say no for
the event let me I'll leave with this I
know it's time to go never say no for
the other person one of the biggest
mistakes that a lot of people make here
and have left a lot of opportunity on
the table is you think that if you were
running that event you wouldn't say yes
to you thus you don't ask never say no
so go down the list of the 50 events hit
him up I want to talk no dude cool go
there no go to there yes boom you just
got something bigger than you thought
got it love it thank you but also be
ghetto and be willing to do the chamber
a [ __ ] Commerce event three minutes
from your house with nine [ __ ]
grandmas in it thank you guys